I'm going to the bathroom okay excuse me
excuse me
give me excuse me excuse me
[Music]
Andre me kid
I'm say where are you you looking for my
boyfriend
girl okay I'm doing it right now dude
Meegan bigger dose me I'm sucking you
Andre Andre we can on your hating come
here
I'm Dre I'm J
Andre I'm J I'm J Siri call Andre
I'm J where I yell a bunch will you
FaceTime me I'm not gonna do it right
now you wouldn't able to see me it's
talkin to you ain't no if I can't
find ya I don't know okay I'm gonna turn
around I'm right there stop
yelling at me okay have you sustained a
head injury or a stroke in last 10
minutes
what do you mean by makin dude put your
phone yep away oMG did you just hang yes
not talking you sir I'm talking my
boyfriend it's me can you see me you
need
give me
evening and
[Music]
I can't find the bathroom